the mayor of kansas city missouri has
reinstated a mass mandate for people in
his city
but he may have to defend it in court
the state's attorney general says he's
suing the mayor
and the city health department to remove
that order maria villareal is in kansas
city maria
what is the mayor's response to this
good morning to you
well good morning gail yesterday we were
actually talking to mayor quinton lucas
and we were focusing on the rise in
covet cases here in kansas city as well
as across the state
with a particular focus on how this
affects children as well
in fact right now we have been able to
confirm 269 kids
tested positive at children's mercy
kansas city hospital
just last week now the hospital says
they have hit capacity
several times recently and they now have
right now
10 kids in their hospital battling covid
that's one of the main reasons why the
city leaders are now requiring people to
wear masks
in public spaces here in kansas city as
we were in our interview
the missouri attorney general tweeted
out that he was filing a lawsuit
asking a judge to ban the mass mandate
which he
argued would protect residents rights
and freedoms
the lawsuit claims lucas does not have
the authority to mandate mask and says
that there's no concrete proof covett
has a substantial impact on children
lucas immediately during our interview
called this
a political move he doesn't
care about covet 19. he doesn't care
about the outbreak in our community
the icu is filled up the young people
getting sick
as the showdown continues in the show me
state
play plays out in court it will continue
to play out in court right now the mass
mandate will stay in place until
a judge says otherwise anthony all right
maria thank you